All through his life. But the tragedy
of how much effort you put out to,
if we want to write about Trump,
if you want to go after like Tybee
did about the financial institution,
the way Thompson did it was to kind
of waste your time later for time now.
And he talks about that. He says, you
mean by that chemical speed? He says,
doing dexedrine being an alcoholic,
sort of changing his life in his rhythms.
He said,
I'm wagering time later for time now I'm
using up energy are things that I might
have by burning the candles so brightly
at this instant cause I believe I need
to go after these moments and I later,
I'm not going to have it,
but I'm making that gamble.
I'm putting the card down right now.
And I think that's terrifying.
And I also think that he gave us
brilliant writing over one of the most
remarkable spans in American
history because of it.
That's a weird tradition of journalism
to destroy your body while creating your
art. And, um, I think there's a, according
to my friends who are journalists,
there's a big problem with Adderall today
and there's a lot of people that are
using it to write and um,
it's fucking speed and you know,
you get addicted.
I mean Adderall makes everything in front
of you closer. Have you done it? Yeah.
So my first book was called hyper.
I'm a personal history of Adhd,
so it was about being medicated as a
child. You were medicated as a child,
like having pills forced down my
throat, like all sold. We you six.
When I took Ritalin for
the first time I had,
I had a suicidal moment
and like six years old.
The first time you were six
you wanted to commit suicide.
I held like a butter knife to my
wrist. I don't remember it. But yeah,
I kind of remember it, but
yeah. And it was on Ritalin,
which I've taken now as an adult and
I always feel startled when I'm on it.
If I ever take Ritalin
now why did he like, well,
I take it to write like this
world is incredibly painful.
So I take Adderall now.
Um, and I, I take it to how
often you take it everyday.
I take like 30 milligrams a day really?
And I take it too,
I take it to go into a library and this
is what David Wallace wells was talking
about,
I think like two days ago on the show was
how do you read really shitty academic
articles where you need the information
from them. I'm not good at that.
I'm not good at even making like
a car reservation, you know,
like a car rental reservation.
And so this world's going to
be painful no matter what.
But there's a functionality that, um,
Adderall allows and it's always a wager.
What Thompson writes about is
whenever something is given,
something else has lost. You never
get anything for free in this world.
Thompson understood that better than
anybody. So with him, with [inaudible],
I'm not going to say Thompson
was hyperactive, I'm not
going to go into that.
But techs a dream, like Geiger was
like, Yo, you're breaking down.
Like you're 26.
You have a wife,
you have a very small child
you're writing right now.
You want to have your career go forward,
you're not doing well.
He and the guy who was like, I'm a doctor,
I had gone through med school, you know,
I'd bid it. I, I'd been overwhelmed. Like
you guy get ran every morning, you know,
he did, he did other things,
but he, he took Dex to train.
So I gave it to Thomson.
And for that small period of time it
helped. I mean for me it's like I,
I, I'm not a good researcher
and maybe I would be now,
but the only way I can write about
something like hunter s Thompson where I
didn't know him,
I had no experience with him,
is to read everything that he's ever
written or been written about him and then
go out and interview people.
And so effort is my only path forward.
And what Adderall helps for me is to
take the pain away of that effort,
but it doesn't take it away.
It shifts it around to other
aspects in other parts of life.
And I think Thompson when he wrote,
he who makes a piece of himself escapes
the pain or gets through the pain of
being a man. We don't listen to that.
Like, he was like, this effort is hard.
He's like,
I'm struggling with this effort.
I'm trying to make these beautiful things.
I always think of James Salter
fiction writer Aspin um, um,
resident rope, beautiful novels. He
wrote his whole life till he was 90.
His last novel was at 87.
He wrote a memoir at 76 about being a
fighter pilot among other things in the
Korean War lyric. Literary he
did it his whole life. He didn't,
he didn't burn out for
a small period of time.
He's the Antonym to Thompson I think when
it comes to effort and literary work.
Right. Um, do, do you
just take it for work?
Yeah,
I mean you don't have like an issue that
you need to take it for all my I where
we will, um, I think that will,
whenever we have something
like chemical speed,
whenever we have something like alcohol,
um,
whenever we have something that's not
like marijuana where at least marijuana
cuts your mania.
You know,
like whenever we have something else like
alcohol or at our all we need ask the
question or is it,
is taking the pain away and
being productive through
those actually hastening
your own doom and I think
with alcohol is very clear.
It is without a roles more complex. I
think if you do an amount of time release,
you can make it work.
How many Americans do that?
Out of the percent that are prescribed,
you know, I don't know, 10%, 20%,
like it's dangerous.
How often do you take time off?
I'd say maybe one or
two weeks, uh, of, uh,
every three or four months. And when
you do that, do you feel weird? No,
I just watch movies. Like I just
don't do anything. It doesn't,
I don't have any productivity.
I don't, I don't produce.
So the only way you produces on speed,
the only way I produce,
the way I want to right now is on speed.
I didn't start taking it till I'm 2010.
[inaudible] it's crazy that we're talking
about this because there's so many
people like you. It's um, it's so calm.
I mean how much of the
work that we enjoy today,
especially literary work
is written by people.
Journalistic work is written by people
that are on speed. But that's not new.
I mean that's what Thompson and burrows
and southern like this has been.
I believe that our American society,
the situation I'm in,
I have created a situation where I
have too much work and it's my fault.
I should not be trying to be a professor
and also go report it competency and
also at George Mason in the
creative writing program, you know,
and also then be hosting like people
coming out and also then like be trying to
research something that might be my
next thing that's too much in the way
Thompson saw dexedrine was that he
could make reality match his effort.
So there was no longer the limit.
It was the American dream idea.
If you just put out enough effort,
you'll get it.
And that's why I think he's
so brilliantly understood.
The toxicity of the American dream is
that the effort is what the story is.
You just because you have a path with
the effort to be rich, to be successful,
that doesn't mean that a good thing.
That's what we'll actually dismantle you.
Yeah. It's putting it out.
And I think we forget that.